- Ask me anything you want to ask me.
- [Mark] Okay.
Anything?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Wow.
- You know, you're right,
I try to lock it out.
You know what I mean?
And that, I think that's
worse trying to block it out.
- [Mark] Oh yes, definitely worse.
To hang on to that stuff
and carry with you--
- [Jennifer] It's like a
fucking backpack full of books.
(Jennifer laughs)
- [Mark] Hold on one second,
I got to do an Uber for somebody.
- Oh, you Uber too, huh?
- [Mark] I do everything for everybody.
I deliver food to people.
I got to do an Uber for this girl.
You know Nikki?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] White girl?
- [Mark] This is her.
She's in Las Vegas now.
She stopped drinking.
- Oh, that's good.
- [Mark] Totally stopped.
Has not had a drink for
probably three weeks.
- That's good.
- [Mark] And she's had a job in Vegas,
but she's got a urinary
tract infection and a
respiratory infection (mumbles).
- Is it Corona?
- [Mark] What's that?
- [Mark] No, no, no.
She's already been in the hospital
and they said no, it's not that.
- That's good.
I've been tested three times.
- [Mark] Where did you get tested?
- Hospital.
You can go right there to Christian Center
and they'll test you.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
Actually, basically it's an easy test,
It's just a temperature.
- [Mark] Is that all they do?
- Yeah, it's all they do.
(Mark mumbles)
If you ain't got no
temperature, you ain't got it.
But they're worried about me because
for one, the HIV.
And then I got asthma and COPD,
so they're kind of worried about me.
But I seem to be doing okay.
- [Mark] Yeah, you seem healthy as can be.
You look better today than you ever have.
- Yeah.
I just woke up, not even 30 minutes ago.
- [Mark] Where are you sleeping now?
- I was at my friend's tent
over there on Central and 15th.
He got me out the rain yesterday.
Just let me sleep it off.
In fact, I don't smoke crack no more.
- [Mark] Oh, you were on crack and heroin?
- Yeah.
I don't do crack no more.
- [Mark] Oh really?
- Yeah.
I do a little crystal.
Crystal helped me get off the crack.
- [Mark] Yeah, I've heard that a lot.
I talked to them--
- And it works.
It works.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure.
Don't get hooked on crystal though.
- Yeah, I know.
I used to shoot it a lot.
I just loved that high, but
then I was getting paranoid.
Like...
- [Mark] So you've used heroin,
you've used crack,
and you've used crystal meth?
- And I've used PCP.
I've used everything.
- [Mark] Tell me the
differences in all these drugs.
- Cocaine, is a stimulant.
It's a straight stimulant.
It just picks you up, but
it drops you real quick.
Speed is a stimulant too,
but it leaves you up there for a while.
But you don't do such drastic stuff.
- [Mark] And a lot of people
say it helps your libido
and all that--
- Oh, yes. It's the bomb.
For sex it's good.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Yeah, you have to try it.
- [Mark] We're getting viewers now,
trying crystal meth just for that.
(Jennifer laughs)
- It's just when I think
about all the chemicals
that they use to cook it up,
all the chemicals are
under your kitchen sink.
- [Mark] Yeah, it's horrible stuff.
- Yeah.
Like what is this stuff?
Liquid plumber?
(Jennifer laughs)
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm done.
And then heroin?
- Yeah, the heroin,
it relaxes you.
Relaxes your whole system.
- [Mark] It makes you
forget about all that...
- Yeah, you're not...
Just like (laughs)
The high just relaxes me, takes me away.
So I don't have to feel.
- [Mark] From all your pain
or whatever memories...
- Yeah.
- [Mark] PCP?
Sure.
- That fucking totally eats
your cells in your head.
- [Mark] It seems to.
The people I've talked to that do PCP--
- I had a friend that
tried to lift the gas pump
out of the fucking ground.
He thought he was that strong.
- [Mark] Well, then there's Spice,
which is...
- Oh my God! I've never tried that.
- [Mark] I know.
That's the poor man's
drug, but it's horrible.
- Yeah, it's killing people.
- [Mark] Oh, it's horrible.
- You know what it is?
It's pesticide they use on...
Plant spray.
- [Mark] Yeah. No, it's horrible stuff.
It's almost the most
destructive of all these drugs.
- Yeah.
And that's why it's becoming more popular.
- [Mark] Yeah. Well, it's
very inexpensive stuff.
- Yeah, a dollar.
- [Mark] Yeah.
(Jennifer laughs)
A dollar for joint, right?
And then what else did we miss?
Anything else?
- That's it.
I'm sick of all this stuff though.
- [Mark] What about pills?
- No, I don't do pills.
- [Mark] So I see you all the time.
You're one of my old
friends from down here.
- Yeah, I think I was
one of the first ones.
- [Mark] Well, when I came to this studio,
but I've had... This is
my third studio down here.
But I think I even
photographed you years before?
- Yeah, maybe.
- [Mark] 'Cause I knew you--
- In Hollywood?
Were you in Hollywood?
- [Mark] No, I was down here.
I've been down here like
10 years on and off.
I wasn't here 10 years straight,
but I was down here and
I left and I came back
and I left again and now I'm here.
The last year I've been here a lot.
So, you had once told me what
happened with your childhood.
Your dad molested you at what age?
- Seven years old.
- [Mark] And it went on for how long?
- Nine years.
- [Mark] And you told me outside
that you're willing to talk about it?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Last time you didn't
really want to get into it
and I don't blame you
and I didn't push so.
But if you want to share
that I think it's...
If you're into sharing it
I think it can be very therapeutic.
- It's just...
He used to tell me that it
was a game that we would play.
A game.
And I didn't understand what he was saying
but in actuality it was a game
because
he was acting like I was his wife
instead of his wife,
and I was his daughter.
So I didn't understand.
It was full sex at seven years old.
So that's how I grew up.
I grew up real fast.
And I thought it was okay.
Until I found out that it was
really, he was abusing me.
- [Mark] And did your mom find out?
- I tried to tell my mom
and she would watch it.
She would watch it.
- [Mark] What do you mean watch it?
- Watch it, just sit there and watch.
I think that he threatened her,
if she didn't watch
that he would kill her.
- [Mark] Jesus.
And you grew up where?
- In Portland, Oregon.
Well, back there was...
In the '70s, there was a
lot of incest going on,
in the church.
- [Mark] I think there's a lot
of incest going on everywhere
- Everywhere.
- [Mark] After doing all these interviews
I think it's like--
- Yeah.
At first it was fondly,
just, touchy.
But then it got more heavy.
And that's what scared me.
- [Mark] And did you ever
confront your dad about this
later in life?
- Yeah, when I went to
prison and I had my son...
I had my son two days later,
my dad was at the prison.
He wanted to see me.
I said, "Okay."
I just totally went off on him.
I said, "Do you see where I'm sitting?
"Do you see where I'm sitting?"
I remember I had a
conversation with my mom
and I said I will never
become a drug addict,
go to prison or be a gangbanger.
That day I (mumbles) my life.
'Cause now I've done all those things.
And I just totally, I
disowned my father that day.
I said, "I never want to see you again.
"I don't want you in my life.
"If this is what it's gonna be about
"I don't need it."
And I hurt him.
So I really think he
died of a lonely heart.
That you could never get...
He apologized, he made his amends to me.
- [Mark] Did he seem to have
remorse for what he did?
- Yeah, he did.
He had tears in his eyes.
He was dying then.
He died the day I got out of prison.
Before I got out, but yeah, he died.
- [Mark] And you were in prison for what?
- I don't wanna talk about that shit.
Nothing serious.
- [Mark] And you had siblings?
- Yeah, I have one sister.
- [Mark] Did she...
- She was abused.
She was abused too.
She doesn't talk about it though.
I think that's what's stopping her from...
She'll never have babies.
- [Mark] Yeah, to me I get...
I see comments like, "how can you
"force these people to
talk about these things?"
But to not talk about them is--
- Is worse.
- [Mark] Is much worse.
- Yeah, 'cause they would kill you.
- [Mark] And if somebody really
doesn't wanna talk about it
like you didn't last time,
I don't pressure you into doing it.
I just let it go.
But for people that are
willing to talk about it
I think it can benefit them
and other people that
have been through that,
and maybe they're not talking about it,
that are watching.
And so you're using drugs
a lot less you told me?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
Sometimes I don't even use meth.
- [Mark] It was about a year ago or so
that we did the first interview.
And you were using how many?
- [Jennifer] Six.
Upto six balloons a day.
- [Mark] Of heroin.
And what are you using now?
- [Jennifer] Sometimes nothing.
- [Mark] What have you had today?
- [Jennifer] Nothing.
- [Mark] Nothing.
What will you use today?
- [Jennifer] I'll probably
do a balloon later on.
- [Mark] One?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- [Mark] So you've gone
from six down to one?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
- [Mark] And you look much better.
- [Mark] Mentally--
- [Jennifer] I've gained a little weight.
- [Mark] Yeah, you seem a
little more healthier, calmer.
Your skin looks better.
Everything looks better.
- [Jennifer] I'm hungry right
now though. Very hungry.
- [Mark] I'll set you
up with something here.
Did you do this on your
own or through a program?
Or how do you do it?
- [Jennifer] On my own.
- [Mark] You did this by yourself?
- [Jennifer] Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] What would you
recommend to somebody
trying to get off of heroin?
- [Jennifer] Go to a meeting.
- [Mark] You know how
many people I've talked to
in the in the 10 years
I've been doing this
that have kicked heroin?
Honestly, they've told
me they've kicked heroin
but the ones that have
actually done it, zero.
Maybe one.
You'll be the first one
that I'm seeing actually happen with.
- [Jennifer] Yeah, I did on my own.
I got tired of living like that.
- [Mark] So you weaned yourself slowly?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
And then with methadone, it helped.
- [Mark] Oh, you're doing methadone too?
- [Jennifer] Yeah.
Methadone saves my life.
It saved my life.
- [Mark] 'Cause you didn't tell that.
- Yeah, methadone. I've been
on methadone since 2014.
I didn't even go and get that today,
it's because it's too late.
- [Mark] And then
what's the long-term plan with methadone?
- Methadone is slowly decreased.
- [Mark] And eventually
you'll be off that?
- Yeah.
If I could get off that
methadone, I would be so happy.
'Cause it fucks you up.
It fucks you up.
It fucks your bones up.
It sets in your bones.
- [Mark] And I'm sure there's a--
- Give you arthritis really bad.
You know who started that, right? Hitler.
For his people,
his army.
- [Mark] Giving them methadone?
- Yeah.
To help him up with the pain.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
And now the federal
government gives it to us.
- [Mark] And you have kids, right?
- Yeah.
My daughter's a brain surgeon.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where?
- USC.
- [Mark] Awesome.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And she knows you're down here?
She's waiting for me to,
tell her to come and pick me up mom.
- [Mark] You're almost there.
- Yeah, I'm almost there.
- [Mark] That's great.
- She calls me, I got her on speed dial.
- [Mark] So you talk to your daughter?
- Yeah, every day.
- [Mark] Every day?
- Every day.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Even if I'm all fucked up I'll be like,
"You don't want to talk to me right now."
And she's like, "Mom, I don't care.
"I don't care."
- [Mark] She doesn't care?
- No.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's beautiful.
- She's helped me.
- [Mark] No, I think that acceptance
and non judgemental interaction.
It works miracle--
- She's like a best
friend that I never had.
She says like, "But mom,
there's rats down here, really?"
(Jennifer and Mark laugh)
- [Mark] Yes, there are.
- Yeah, she just turned 32.
- [Mark] She's a brain surgeon?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Wow.
- She'll never be without a job.
She got top honors.
She was a Valedictorian of her class.
She was like number two in the class.
- [Mark] And she was raised by...
- Me.
- [Mark] You raised her?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So you've been living
on the streets since when?
- Yeah, since
1985.
- [Mark] So '85, she was how old?
- She was... I had her in '88.
- [Mark] So hold on.
You were homeless when
you had your daughter?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you raised her where?
- Well, through family,
through my aunts and stuff.
She would come with me
for a little while and--
- [Mark] But she wasn't
staying on Skid Row?
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
- [Mark] She was staying with family?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then you would come and go?
- [Mark] All right, so.
So you had some help?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's great.
But you certainly was
doing something, right?
- My kids were never into foster
homes or nothing like that.
They don't know nothing about that.
They don't judge me for
being in the drug world.
She says, "Mom, everybody
has her skeletons."
- [Mark] Don't you as an addict,
feel like that's almost
the most important element
in recovery?
- Yeah. Not to judge.
- [Mark] To not be made to feel bad.
- [Jennifer] And you don't
forget where you come from too.
- [Mark] I'm sorry.
- [Jennifer] You don't
forget where you come from.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Jennifer] You can
always end up back there.
Every time you fall, it's that much worse.
I've made 25 steps...
I'll take 100 steps and then come back 50.
- [Mark] Yep.
Well, Jennifer, it's so great to see you.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] I see you all the time but--
- Thank you for listening to me.
(Mark and Jennifer laugh)
- [Mark] You're amazing.
I'm so proud of you.
- Thanks.
- [Mark] And I'm proud
of your daughter too.
- [Jennifer] Thank you.
I'ma bring her down here.
I'm gonna bring her...
Well, maybe go have lunch or something.
- [Mark] That'd be cool.
I'd love it here.